welcome back so where I left off we said
that we had this this I guess we could
call it equation or this function
although I didn't write it with the
function notation where I said the
distance is equal to 16 T squared and I
graph that it's like a parabola right
for positive time and then we said well
the velocity if we know the distance the
velocity is just the change of the
distance with respect to time and since
the velocity is always changing you
can't just take the slope you'd actually
have to take the derivative right so we
took the derivative with respect to time
of this function or this equation and we
got 32 T and this is the velocity and
then we graphed it and then I asked a
question I was like well we want to
figure out if we were given this if we
were given just this and I asked you you
what what is what is the distance that
this object travels after time you know
ty after 10 seconds let's you know let's
say this t0 is equal to 10 seconds I
want to know how far has this thing gone
after 10 seconds and let's say you
didn't know that you could just take the
antiderivative let's say we didn't know
this at all and let's say you didn't
know that you could just take the
antiderivative because we just showed
that you know that the derivative of
distance is velocity so the
antiderivative of velocity is distance
so let's say you couldn't just take the
antiderivative what's the way that you
could start to try to approximate how
far you've traveled after say 10 seconds
well when I says you graph this and you
say let's say let's assume over some
change in time let's assume over some
change in time velocity is roughly
constant right let's say velocity is
right here so you could approximate how
far you travel over that small change in
time by multiplying that change in time
let's say that's like you know a
millionth of a second times the velocity
at roughly that time or maybe even the
average velocity over that time and
you'd get you would get the distance
you've traveled over that very small
that very small fraction of time right
but if you look at it visually that ox
that also happens to be the area of this
rectangle right and what we said is if
you wanted to know how far you travel
after 10 seconds you just draw a bunch
of you just do a bunch of these
rectangles and you sum up the area
right and you can imagine and you don't
have to imagine it's actually true
the more that the smaller the basis of
these rectangles and the more of these
rectangles you have the fat up the more
accurate your your approximation will be
and you'll approach to things you'll
approach the area under this curve right
almost the exact area under this curve
and you'd also get almost the exact
almost the exact value of the of the
distance after say ten seconds in this
case right but ten didn't have to be an
exact number it could have been a
variable so this is something pretty
interesting all of a sudden we see that
the anted the antiderivative is pretty
darn similar to the area under the curve
and it actually turns out that the same
thing and this and this is where I'm
going to teach you the indefinite
integral so the indefinite integral I
don't know how comfortable you are with
salvation I remember the first time I
learned calculus I wasn't that
comfortable with summation but it's
really all the indefinite integral is is
you can kind of view it as a sum right
so now you'll maybe understand a little
bit more why this symbol looks kind of
like a Sigma that's actually how I view
it and please look it up so you can see
properly drawn integrals but in this
case the indefinite integral is just
saying well I'm going to take the sum
from T equals zero right so from T
equals zero so let's say in this example
T equals ten right because I said ten
from T equals zero to T equals ten and
I'm going to take the sum of each of the
heights the height at any given point
right the height at any given point
which is the velocity which is the
velocity and then what's the formula for
the velocity is 32 T 32 T and then I'm
at times the base at each at each at
each of these rectangles DT
and so this is the definite integral the
definite integral is literally and they
never do this in math text and that's
what always kind of confuse me is that
you can kind of view it like a sum like
this it's kind of the sum of each of
these rectangles but it's the limit as
it's that you know if we if we actually
had if these were discrete rectangles
you could just do a sum and you can make
this the rectangle basis smaller and
smaller and have more more rectangles
and just to a regular sum and actually
that's how if you have a write a
computer program to approximate an
integral or approximate the area under
curve that's the way a computer program
would actually do it but the the actual
indefinite integral says well this is
the sum but it's the limit as the basis
of these rectangles gets smaller and
smaller and smaller and smaller and we
have more and more and more of these
rectangles so if you know as as these DT
is approach zero and then the number of
rectangles actually approach infinity so
I'm actually going to I'll do that more
rigorously later but I think it's very
important to get this intuitive feel of
just what an integral is it isn't just
you know this voodoo that happens to be
there but anyway so it's going back to
the problem so the integral from of the
integral this is now a definite integral
we're saying from T equals 0 to T equals
10 this tells us two things this tells
us the area of the curve from T equals 0
to T equals 10 right it tells us this
whole area and it also tells us how far
the object has gone after 10 seconds
right so there's very interesting the
indefinite integral tells us two things
it tells us area and it also tells us
the antiderivative right we're already
familiar with it as an antiderivative so
let's let me give you another example or
actually maybe I'll stick with this
example but I'll I'll clear it a bit
actually maybe I should erase actually
erasing might be a good option with this
one since it's a fairly messy I think
you know all this stuff now I'm just
need space maybe ok so we have that
indefinite integral and we can actually
figure it out - I mean well after T
seconds well if so and the way you
evaluate an indefinite
and let me show you that first is that
you you figure out the integral so let
me let me just say let me continue with
the problem actually as you can tell I
don't plan much these presentations so
the way you figure out the indefinite
integral is you say and sometimes they
won't write T equals 0 at T equals T
they'll just say from 0 to 10 of 32 T DT
right and the way you evaluate this is
you figure out the antiderivative and
you really don't have to do the plus C
here so the antiderivative we know is 16
T squared right it's 1/2 T squared times
32 so that's 16 T squared T squared and
we evaluate this at 10 and we evaluated
it as 0 and then we subtract the
difference so we evaluate this at 10 so
16 times 100 right that's evaluated at
10 and then we subtract it evaluated 0
so 16 times 0 is 0 so after 10 seconds
we have gone 1600 feet and also the area
under this curve is 1600 is 1600
actually I guess yeah it would be 1600
so let's use this to do a couple more
examples and actually I'm going to show
you why we do this this subtraction
actually I'm gonna do that right now let
me clear it
oh that's that's ugly
okay I'll now do it more general
actually let me draw this twice once for
the once for the distance and once for
its derivative
so let's say that the distance yeah well
let's also say it looks let's say it
looks something like this let's say
let's say you start at some distance and
then it goes up like that all right so
let's say we call this distance B well
let's just call this you know I don't
know five right we start at five feet
and then we move we we move forward from
there
right and this this axis is the first
time this exits maybe I shouldn't do
five because it looks so much like s
that's five five feet and this is the S
or distance axis and actually I just
looked at the clock I'm running out of
time so let me continue this in the next
presentation